sky you are no stranger to being bold
online especially when it comes to
responding to negativity I have to
actually what was the catalyst that made
you say enough is enough
I'm calling people out for me I would
just always get damns from my fans
because people know I'm an advocate for
anti bullying so I would always just
look at my messages and see a bunch of
my fans saying look at what this person
said to me and I don't know how to deal
with this and for a moment I'm like hang
I don't know what to do about it maybe
I'm gonna speak out about it but the
more I saw it like it became like twenty
in a day I was like you know what no I'm
gonna down on about it because I think
it's really important and people go
through these struggles every day in
life and for me it's kind of like my
duty with the big platform that I have
is to use it for good how many games do
you think you've received so far like up
until today I want to say in the last
three days I probably received like 3000
DMS of people just trying to expose
races people who are saying very
disgusting things and it's sick because
I never would have thought that there
would be 3,000 people in my DM waiting
for me to respond but all these receipts
and it's just so crazy well how do you
decide for who to actually expose I just
need to see a bunch of evidence because
some people might joke around or trying
to get someone in trouble so my screen
recording or if there's a video of them
saying the n-word or a racial slur that
I'm like okay that's the one but if
there's not enough proof and it seems a
little bit sketchy to me then I love
just because I don't know if it's true
or false but my fans have been good with
sending me enough receipts Lila yeah did
you have the fear at all of exposing
somebody who didn't really do anything
wrong I did have the fear but I was like
you know what I'm just gonna trust my
fans and I know that if they're sending
me these things that it's most likely
true but I am a little bit cautious
still but it is in the back of my head
but I'm not too afraid of it when I saw
the story my concern mainly was for you
I mean this is dangerous territory what
do you what do you think the
implications
would be from you outing people my thing
is if you don't like it if you don't
support it then obviously that just does
something I look about you yourself to
kind of support these people who are
saying these disgusting things so I mean
in the back of my head I was a little
bit worried about it I'm like I don't
know what is this gonna harm me but in
my opinion I feel like it's done more
justice for me and other people and
people have been praising me about it
and it's not something that I did just
for either attention or wines be praised
it's solely off of the fact because I do
have a big platform but I'm gonna use
that platform for good so it's always in
the back of my head but I feel like I'm
good we are in a time where people who
are races are getting angry because
things are shifting right and read them
- I don't the last thing I want to
happen is for them to direct that anger
towards you because you are making such
bold moves online what is the
conversation been with your mother I
know you two are close have you all
talked about this before no we didn't
talk about I decided to do it I just
kind of thought I was like you know what
what the heck I'm just gonna do it but
my mom is really supportive of what I do
and she loves that I'm using my platform
for create and it just has my back so I
might think for me is it's like people
can say whatever they want but if you're
that bold to go on a public platform and
say these things please don't get mad
when someone addresses it and that's
simple I'm doing so if you're saying
this to a hundred people what's the
difference between a hundred people to a
million people saying it you said were
you setting you said what you said and
obviously you meant it so I'm just like
if you don't want people to know if you
don't want people to be mad then you
simply just should have made those
videos and made those statements for
people who might not have seen what
you're actually exposing some of the
comments what is one of the worst things
that you've seen so far
one of the worst remarks without
actually saying it but just give me the
gist of it one of the worst remarks
honestly is just screaming the n-word at
people or just people making fun of like
doing blackface
what I saw was disgusting they had like
a
the ghetto party and they were doing
blackface and like oh we're Travis Scott
and all these things are you serious
yeah I'm just like how dare you like
what about Travis Scott makes him ghetto
and a thug like that's what I don't
understand so I mean people are that
bold to do these things it just it's
appalling for me there's already been
action from your tweets actor Hartley
Sawyer was fired from the flash what was
your reaction to that for me honestly I
didn't know who he was just a lot of my
fans we're sending me his tweets and
ice' noticed that he was verified but
I'm just like what he was saying I don't
know if you saw it was just utterly
disgusting so verified or not I'm gonna
say what I have to say and I mean he got
fired that sucks but he's grown he's old
enough to know that those things that
you say those homophobic slurs those
racist slurs are just not okay they're
not okay period you're not 14 you're not
13 even so if you are that age it's
still not okay but you know for me my
thing is I just really want like even a
lot of colleges um a lot of my fans have
tweeted at the colleges and they've
actually been really good and they've
responded I'm not trying to ruin
someone's entire life it's just that
these colleges should be aware I'm this
what students that they're bringing in
what do you want the colleges to do
moving forward because I saw some of
your posts you would say just
acknowledging it and saying okay we're
gonna give this to the admissions
portion of our of our organization is
not enough what do you want from those
institutions I don't feel like someone
who says these things shouldn't be
allowed to go to college but I feel like
maybe you should just do online maybe if
you have so and if you're gonna be going
to a college that's mainly black and
you've said these things I don't think
it's okay to put those people in an
uncomfortable situation because I'm also
sure after all of this that their future
college friends have seen it and that
might make them feel a certain way so
for me they can take it I've given them
the information they can take and do
whatever they want
but I feel like maybe just doing online
is better have you heard from anybody
directly that says you know that's I've
said I'm gonna change or I'm sorry or
apologize or anything I perceived some
um one of the first people who I kind of
posted about they contacted one of my
friends because little did I know that
they knew my friend and they were just
like please like you know just begging
and I'm just like listen I didn't do
this to ruin your life or do anything to
make it seem in a really bad way but you
said what you said and I posted it and
they were you know begging me to delete
it and I'm just like I understand but
even if I delete it now people have
already seen it so I'm just glad that
they're taking the time to educate
themselves now a lot of the people have
written public apologies which is really
nice but I just really hope that they're
not just saying this so keep it off of
there but I really hope that they learn
from this and educate themselves because
everyone does make mistakes but it's up
to you to learn from them and move
forward what I found interesting is that
your fans who are coming in your DM
they're not bold enough to say it
themselves so they come to you to say
how do how does it feel to be looked at
as that person you know to actually call
out races for me it's just something
that I'm happy that I can do for my fans
because a lot of my fans go through
these things they only have what a
couple hundred followers so they think
no one's gonna see this I'm gonna have
to deal with this person bullying me
sending me these racial slurs so if I
can help them in any way I'm happy to do
so and actually there's been a lot of
verified people in my team with a lot of
followers telling me to expose people
which was really surprising but I could
count how they over 100 what do you say
to critics who feel like you're putting
these people in danger by exposing them
I personally don't think I'm putting
them in danger because I'm not exposing
anything that's private that's one thing
I won't do everything that is said is
public information
posted these videos it's out there to
the public I would a lot of people have
been trying to get me to post their
address and number and I'm like no no no
no no that's one thing I will not do
I'm only posting public information
nothing that is private so personally I
don't feel like I am putting them in any
type of harm because putting someone
inside from harm would be exposing
information that is private so how long
do you plan on doing this I know you
said you were gonna come back Wednesday
which is tomorrow and start again
well Wednesday I don't think I'm gonna
do that many people I'm just probably
gonna do 10 the most but after that I'm
probably gonna take a break and just
take a breather from it don't know when
I'll do it again but if I see a lot of
my fans still coming in my dance maybe
like in the next one or two months but
it's not for me it's not gonna be like
everything but sure I have so many other
things to do so I can't just be focused
on that but once in a while possibly if
you have had one lesson or just sum up
the lesson for me that you want people
to learn the people that you're outing
what is it that you want them to know I
just want them to know that words
sometimes do hurt no matter how strong
the person is and that us black people
already going through so much right now
in the world and for you to think it's
okay to use those racial slurs against
us it's just disgusting to me and I
really hope and pray that you educate
yourself do your history and understand
why saying the n-word and all these
other things are not okay people just
think it's a joke and let people just
say it for fun you know I walk down the
street and people are like hey you know
and weird and it's just like I perceive
I'm going up into you know not to me
photos like we are like you want their
friends but I personally just don't
think it's a word that should be used I
don't like the word it has a very very
strong meaning behind it
so I just hope that like I said people
educate themselves do their history and
just don't say the word it's it's really
not that hard
last week you tweeted quote I see a lot
of Yahoo have a big platform and not
speaking on what's been going on
in the world is there someone in
particular you would like or you would
have expected to speak up by now you
know I've seen since then a lot of
people speak up like the Kardashians
that spoke about it charli's Emilio used
her platform the best time tick tock but
you know there's people who are out
there and instead of looting with people
and doing terrible things just to cause
drama
why don't you use your platform to speak
up and to speak up and say we should all
stick together peacefully protest rather
than acting foolish in the street and
kind of just wanting to put the
attention on themselves so I feel like
if you have a big platform please use it
for great just like me just like a bunch
of people are it takes two seconds it's
not gonna mess up your Instagram feed
you can do it but I just think everyone
who has a big platform and I'm not even
just saying millions of followers if you
have ten thousand two thousand you
should still be using a platform for
great I want to know what is been your
experience add the black celebrity as a
former Disney Channel star what is your
experience when it comes to dealing with
racism I have dealt with racism in my
career it's at times really hard people
think like why would people be you know
towards me but it happens and it's the
truth
but you know I'm strong and I know I can
get through anything but it can be a
little bit of a downer at times well
right now a lot of people are looking at
you as a superhero you know there are
some critics of course I just personally
want you to stay safe you know I am
seeing it vibes your way thank you so
much